welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just to our listeners and viewers but to
the man to my right as the big time run
rich run is coming up in Indianapolis
and joining me here right now is an
angel an angel a man who gave a ton of
money to run rich run last year and ran
himself the CEO of Walmart ecommerce us
the president and CEO of that mark Lorie
good to see you sir how rich you ready
to go back here ready to go back to Indy
sir I am I am now when you say you're
ready I did do a little training this
year okay unlike last year now last year
you just went out and just
you just ran nothing in 30 years yeah
what do you mean nothing and like didn't
that's the first time I sprinted in 30
years last year and my first time at all
and it's not easy right everyone thinks
it's just 40 yards yeah right it was
tough it's not we had Israel out of
Sanya the the UFC fighter a couple of
weeks ago and he's like 40-yard dash
she goes that's nothing that goes I
thought you're running a marathon no I'm
like it's explosive people aren't
supposed to explode late now come on how
old are you you're already eight forty
eight I'm 50 you're right we're not
supposed to explode like that how fast
did you run it last year though last
year was 537 I know impressive I know
now you what are we doing but you know
that this year okay well before we get
to that though excuse me did you run it
in a suit and jeans in a jacket jeans in
a jacket jeans are generally more
constrictive I swam 5-3 in change in a
jeans in a sport coat cooking
I forgot you or the sport coat but the
jeans they were kind of expandable
similar the ones that you're wearing
right now okay well it's funny because
last year and again you were so generous
last year to now again you just you just
went online right one time one day
looking - yeah it was basically looking
to different charities for children
basically and came across you know st.
Jude's and it's something that I was
reading about and
passionate about wanting to give money
donate money too and I saw your run came
up yes I was like oh oh that's so fun
40-yard dash you know and and I thought
let me call you up and see if I can you
know get in on that and make it more of
a fun thing and yeah and so that's how
you started and so then you ran and you
you donate it I'll say it may I say how
much you donate a hundred thousand
dollars last year which was amazing just
absolutely amazing and so so incredibly
generous and and true to you sir is you
came off the turf in Indy and you
immediately said to me we got to make
this bigger next year yeah you're like
we got to make it because next year and
you came up with an idea right and I
give you the floor on your your idea
that you came up with for this year's
yeah it was just first of all I was
inspired by you and and I think it's a
great cause and everything you drinkin
st. Jude is incredible and I'm glad to
see the people out there that are
putting time into into helping others
like you have and and I just wanted to
help you and be a part of it making it
bigger and I thought if we can get you
know athletes involved eventually could
could help raise more money and build
more awareness on the two and so I just
happened Michael Rubin who's a friend of
mine we just happen to be talking about
this and and brainstorming cuz he's in
you know runs fanatics and does
relationships with athletes and things
you know somehow it came up Jerry Rice
you know racing Jerry Rice and he's like
dude you're gonna get so smoked and I
said all right well let's bet you you
know let's say if I win you donate 250
grand to st. Jude's mmm he goes done you
know like he was just he was like
there's no way you beaten Jerry Rice
that's fine
ran he's like and if you lose you're
donating right I said yeah yeah if I
lose I'll donate 250 if you it Jerry
happen to beat Jerry you'll do it okay
so that's where we're at now hopefully
we can get some other people to could
have climb on board as well and
piggyback off that well and the first
things first was to get you know the
goat on board because Jerry Rice is
Jerry Rice and I warned you
what you might be messy
with when you wanted that bowl that got
some serious horns let's roll some tape
right here for mark Lori hey bar hurt
you had this crazy idea racing against
me in the 40-yard debt and then if I
beat you you would donate a bunch of
money to st. Jude so get the money ready
because the race is on and you gonna pay
up
see you in bike training you know what
can I just tell you something funny
though when when when I agreed to do
this with Michael Rubin yes when when
Jerry Rice his name came up I had in my
mind think you know he's a few years
older don't all these NFL guys kind of
get you know fat and out of shape you
know and so I went and I go after the
bed I went in Google Jerry Rice I put
Jerry Rice in shape thing comes up he's
like Adonis like not a fun cover of ESPN
ripped I'm like this must have been like
15 20 years ago it's like now that was
like two years ago
so at that point I was a maybe Michael
knew better
well you know no look when it comes to
Jerry he ran a four seven one at his
combine back in the 80s and he is how do
I put it again you are the president and
CEO of Walmart ecommerce so you come
across some some highly motivated
individuals mark Lori okay whoever those
people are that you've come across in
business as competitors nothing compared
to Jerry Rice I mean he is despite being
57 years of age like one of the most
vicious competitors I've ever met and
come across so he has no intention of
losing to you whatsoever
so well to make it close of course okay
what I've been training okay good
been training for the last few months
okay doing some sprints and I'm gonna be
faster than last
yes LLC well here's a neat thing about
it about for us you and I together on
this is that last year if you remember
we ran it late in the afternoon like
right before dinner time because we all
had to wait for you know a little thing
called the Scouting Combine day three to
finish up this time though they've
switched for the first time the combine
all the on-field drills is held at night
okay so we get to go like first thing in
the morning like we get to wake up we
get to have the proper breakfast we get
to warm up like normal people before
they run something like this and we get
to go and you know run as opposed to
wait all day breakfast then lunch sit
around sit on your ass we're ready to go
so excellent that's a benefit for us
this year is a schedule so question for
you you don't go subset Craig question
mark that's the plan I've got a little
planter fashion issue in my left foot is
that what are you wait what are you
shaking your head for dealing with the
planter since the fall that's what
happens and you keep town I mean it
should have rolled the baseball under
your foot or healed yeah I have you ever
heard that is it you have your very
plant of fashion no but I have another
problem I was I was reading you know he
had it said goat yes yeah mine should
say gout yeah it comes and goes
I thought that was like a very very good
turn of the phrase so yes I think if he
wears his goat hat I wear my gown
well here's the best part about it is
st. jude's a winner yep
because you are a like I said an angel
that you want to do this sort of thing
and obviously having fun and getting
Jerry involved there will be way there
will be coming up a way just hit the run
rich run button the donate button at
nfl.com slash run rich we run it will
take you to a page where you can pledge
all money goes to st. Jude you can
pledge your dollars in support of you or
Jerry that's coming up so get ready for
that then of course you could make a
donate to st. Jude
period end a story there's many
different ways that you can do
and of course you run wherever you are
in your work outfit in a safer manner at
work upload the video and then hit that
donate button and you will see your
videos on on NFL Network if they are as
good as I hope they are and you serve
our great people man thank you for
coming in here oh thank you Carrie is
ready for you yeah Jerry is Jerry is
ready for you we'll see what we can do
okay and again nfl.com slash run rich
run donate to st. Jude in you can pledge
on behalf of mark Lori again the
president and chief executive officer of
Walmart ecommerce or Jerry Rice the
greatest of all times for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app